vous avez d'un côté la ministre fédéral
des sports parce qu'elle s'interroge qui
est contre la participation des athlètes
alors que le Comité olympique canadien
lui et pour mais sous certaines
conditions alors ce débat ce soir on va
les carnets avec nos deux invités celui
qui est pour ces Dominique Gauthier
exolympien et celui qui est contre c'est
Martin Leclerc chroniqueur et analyse
sportif bonsoir à vous deux
bons Dominique je vais commencer avec
vous vous êtes pour la participation des
athlètes russes et Belarus pourquoi
ouais mais en fait je suis pour puis je
vais mettre la table d'abord de dire que
je pense que dans ce conflit là dans ce
débat là qu'on a même moins Martin et
plusieurs personnes sur les réseaux
sociaux qu'on voit se prononcer je
trouve qu'on saute un petit peu vite aux
conclusions et que on ne lit pas tous
les détails de l'Annonce comme celle du
Comité olympique canadien la semaine
dernière on a seulement pris le grand
titre mais on n'a pas pris le temps de
bien analyser donc je dis oui mais voilà
où j'en suis bon et vous Martin
que moi je suis tout à fait contre la
participation de la Russie et du Belarus
aux Jeux Olympiques pour plusieurs
raisons premièrement je crois
fondamentalement que le monde du sport
n'est pas une bulle isolée du reste de
la société les gens qui font du sport et
les organismes de sport font partie
intégrante sont le reflet de la société
dans laquelle dans laquelle nous vivons
et on voit une tendance extrêmement
alarmante depuis plusieurs années au
sein des grandes organisations de sport
international qui fréquentent les
dictateurs de ce monde comme si rien
n'était comme si c'était des citoyens
ordinaires du reste de la communauté
internationale on a vu la Russie obtenir
les Jeux Olympiques qu'on a vu la Chine
obtenir les Jeux Olympiques et alors
qu'il se passe des choses extrêmement
graves dans ces pays-là et ça ça avalise
la conduite de ces dictateurs et en se
collant sur les dictateurs de ce monde
les dirigeants des grands organisations
sportives vont à l'encontre du message
que le propage disent on dit toujours
que c'est le sport ça sert à unir les
êtres humains à faire la promotion de la
fraternité entre les peuples etc alors
qu'on donne plus d'influence et de
pouvoir à ceux qui justement vont contre
ces valeurs là alors ça c'est
mon portrait d'ensemble pour me poser à
la participation de la Russie aussi je
reviens Dominique avec son oui mais quel
est le mec quelles conditions vous
trouvez ça acceptable en fait il y a
plusieurs conditions mais d'abord faut
regarder les faits et le CIO faut
comprendre que et d'un selon moi ça ne
devrait pas être la police
internationale de ce qui est bien ce qui
est mal et de qui a raison qui a tort
lorsqu'on parle de conflit qui pourrait
être religieux comment retraiter ça et
aussi il faut comprendre que c'est
l'Organisation des Nations Unies
l’onuellement qui pour plus tard qu'au
mois de décembre en recommandé et plus
que recommander ils ont même passé une
résolution pour imposer au CO de ne pas
traiter les athlètes russes et Bélarus
ou tout autre athlète de les discriminer
par rapport à leur passeport donc c'est
même au-delà du CIO on voit que l'ONU se
présente en support est-ce que le CIO
est en train de faire maintenant comment
on va traiter ça c'est ce qui se passe
présentement c'est que en lisant juste
le grand site faut comprendre que le CIO
présentement n'a pas dit qu'il voulait
avoir les athlètes russes et bellauses à
Paris ils n'ont jamais dit ça tout ce
qu'ils ont dit c'était que il
considérait à regarder une éventualité
dans lequel vous voyez le truc les les
justement il joue avec les ondes grises
vous avez pas tort mais ils n'ont jamais
dit pour l'instant qu'il voulait voir
les athlètes à Paris ils veulent juste
trouver une solution dans l'éventualité
que le conflit se termine et qu'on doit
réintégrer ces athlètes-là rappelons les
conditions c'est bannière neutre
c'est-à-dire il y aura pas de drapeau de
la Russie par exemple sous bannière
neutre et en notant aussi que ces mêmes
athlètes n'est pas fait de propagande
progaires finalement le sois tenu loin
de toute cette affaire là Martin jour-là
dessus parce que dans le fond spa de la
faute des athlètes ce que fait leur
dirigeants de pays est-ce qu'il fait pas
une facture trop lourde
[Musique]
on n'aurait jamais de recommandations de
l'ONU d'interdire aux Russes de
participer aux Jeux Olympiques les
Russes ont un droit de veto à l'ONU mais
pour le reste je pense que le droit de
participer aux Jeux Olympiques n'est pas
n'est pas un droit sacré et il y a un
problème de cohérence aussi à peu près
tous les pays accidentaux ce sont donnés
la main pour aider les Ukrainiens dans
ce conflit pour les armées pour les pour
financer pour s'assurer que qu'il puisse
tenir le coup se défendre et des
sanctions économiques qui ont été prises
à l'encontre à peu près tous les
secteurs d'activités en Russie et au
Bélarus et là soudainement pendant qu'on
dépense des centaines de millions de
dollars pour envoyer par exemple des
chars d'assaut là-bas pour aider les
Ukrainiens à se défendre on dirait on
dirait aux athlétus ben oui vous venez
jouer venir faire du tir à l'arc et de
l'athlétisme avec nous ça nous fait
plaisir alors il y a un problème de
cohérence aussi le but de toutes les
sanctions qui ont été prises contre la
Russie c'est de rendre le plus de
inconfortables
on cherche à créer une pression
domestique à l'intérieur même de la
Russie j'aimerais relancer Dominique
là-dessus sur cet aspect de cohérence
parce qu'effectivement il y a des pays
qui sont privés d'énergie même en Europe
avec dans ce souci de cohérence avec les
sanctions qui se disent ça va faire mal
nos profs citoyens mais on veut créer un
étau on veut étouffer une certaine façon
la Russie pour qu'elle se retire de
l'Ukraine Martel disait les Jeux
Olympiques c'est une occasion aussi de
dorer la pilule de se mettre en valeur
il y a bien des gens des chefs d'État
qui l'utilisent l'instrumentalisme
finalement pour pour faire de la
propagande pour élargir leur influence
est-ce que vous avez fait un souci aussi
avec ça
les jeux sont politiques je vais pas je
vais pas débattre contre ce fait mais en
même temps de mettre cette
responsabilité là sur un organisme qui
se doit en fait d'être un organisme qui
organise une compétition sportive oui
c'est une compétition de nations j'en
conviens mais là au bout de ligne pour
moi on vient tellement pénaliser briné
potentiellement des athlètes des
individus juste parce que ils sont dans
le pays duquel un dictateur est en train
de faire une invasion une guerre qui est
inacceptable alors que ce qu'on parle
dans le code dopage mais là bien sûr ça
vient périmer en soi l'événement en soi
qui est une discipline sportive ils ont
triché c'était systémique là je suis sûr
qu'il disait qu'on aurait même dû être
plus fort contre la Russie à ce
moment-là quand on parle de gaz ça va
s'arrêter où parce que là si on fait ça
on est en train d'installer un beau
précédent qui fait qu'après chacune des
gars on va regarder le Comité
international olympique on va dire
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire qu'est-ce
que vous devriez faire donc où on trace
la ligne
beaucoup sur les épaules parce que c'est
ça sinon le but c'est comme si devenait
la police mondiale on met un jugement
moral sur chacun des secteurs qui
viennent crise et on décide toi tu as le
droit toi tu as pas le droit toi tu es
le gentil toi tu es le méchant
finalement alors je comprends votre
malaise ici Martin dans vous avez écrit
un texte aussi là-dessus et vous avez
dit j'aimerais que vous l'expliquer vous
trouvez que le monde du sport est
actuellement avec cet exemple là à la
croisée des chemins et que le CIO doit
apporter doit adopter une posture morale
d'une certaine façon donc il doit se
renforcer oui absolument et l'histoire
du mouvement olympique et pavé de faux
pas de de de de
gens remplis de bonnes pensées on a tenu
des Jeux Olympiques en 1936 à Berlin
dans une période extrêmement mouvementée
de l'histoire où c'était très
controversé et
l'autre déjà olympiques était Adolf
Hitler et on a vu on a vu ce qui s'est
passé par la suite le je trouve que le
mouvement en épique n'est jamais gagné
en se collant sur des gens qui BA droits
humains qui attaquent leurs voisins qui
font fit de l'esprit olympique même et
la croisée des chemins pour moi c'est
que un moment donné il faut adopter une
posture morale c'est difficile d'adopter
une règle qui va s'appliquer à tous les
conflits mais on fera du cas par cas
dans ce cas là ici ce sont les
Américains à un moment donné qui est
envahissent un pays sans que ce soit
sans que ce soit mérité ou avalisés
ils seront privés d'envoyer leurs
athlètes aux Jeux Olympiques aussi mais
il faut cesser de donner l'occasion aux
mauvais citoyens internationaux de ce
monde de profiter des vitrines de sport
internationales pour redorer leur image
et pour projeter une image une sensation
de normalité mais c'est une gravité de
pouvoir jouir de cette vitrine alors
qu'ils sont en train de commettre des
exactions mais ça c'est intéressant vous
entendre parce que ça ne vous amène à
réfléchir beaucoup pour les peaux pour
les cons avec Dominique qui pense lui
qui se soucie davantage de l'athlète
qu'il ne voit pas comme responsable du
conflit mais qui paye une lourde note
par la suite messieurs merci beaucoup
pour ce débat